that negative voice inside your head
that's telling you that you suck and you
can't do it that's not actually your
voice that's not you telling yourself
that you suck that voice was planted
there that voice was put there by
somebody else in your life and probably
early on growing up telling you that you
can't do something you were not born you
didn't come out of the womb and say I
suck I can't do anything no you're
playing you're experimenting you're
finding Joy you're laughing you're
you're doing it and then along the way
people tell you that you can't do it
that you should stop that you should
quit that that it's not going to work
out that you can't do it want to sore
get a mentor hey it's Nina carmichel and
we made these videos is probably because
you're the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more and you need that Porche by
surround yourself with the best so today
let's learn from one of the best my
husband Evan carmichel and learn how to
destroy the negative voice in your head
enjoy and we've been so conditioned
around that that we take it on and we
think it's our
voice when you come up with an idea
right just Workshop this you come up
with an idea like I'm going to I'm going
to go I'm going to write a book I'm
going to start a YouTube channel I'm
going to launch this business I'm going
to whatever you come with your your
bucket list your your dream life your
vision board you come with a list of
ideas things that you think that you
want to do things that you feel
confident that you'd love to create for
yourself right okay what happens to next
day the next day it's not even telling
our friends you know I think we we blame
our friends and say well we tell our
friends and they're going to be negative
and and they they they crap on our idea
and so we don't do it well before that
happens we crap on our own ideas right
you look at that list the next day and
say I can't do that who who who was I
yesterday this crazy person that I used
to be yesterday who thought I could do
that it's ourselves telling ourselves
that we suck but the problem problem is
we've taken on that voice and we think
that it's us that's not your voice that
is not your voice telling you that you
suck that is somebody else's voice that
was planted in your head that has been
conditioned to be there that we're so
used to being there that we have taken
on as our voice it has become your
identity but it was not your voice it
was put there it was a seed that was
planted that has been grown over time
and you need to rip that weed out that
is not your voice
you do not think that you
suck it's other people with low
expectations who hate their own lives
who at some point went and tried
something that did not work out for
their life and now nobody around them
can have success because it makes them
look and feel bad and so they spend
their time ripping other people down and
apart that's who planted that weed in
your head that might hit pretty hard I
hope it does cuz when that H when if you
can actually
digest that what ends up happening is
you think oh who whose voice is that who
whose voice is in my head and that's
great awareness to know that it's not
your voice and then to identify whose
voice it is who told you these things
who made you feel this way growing up
and if you think about who that person
is if you can actually picture somebody
oh that was Uncle Joe or oh that was my
grade three teacher oh or that was my
you know the bully at school whoever
that person was now think about okay
it's that person's voice not you that's
already incredibly
liberating but then too do you want to
live that person's life like think about
that person probably they're not living
a great life they're not hitting their
potential they're not even happy with
what they're doing if somebody's
spending their day tearing other people
down what kind of painful life does that
person have to have when they go home
you don't want their life if you don't
want their life then you definitely
don't want their voice in your head
anymore hopefully that creates an aha
moment for you that starts to actually
shift things because we've been so
conditioned to listen to that voice that
we don't recognize that we actually have
a choice to rip it out and start to
listen to our own
voice so that's step one step two then
is whatever you want more of in your
life you need to be surrounded by it
more you need to change the en
environment your environment has been
perfectly designed to keep you where you
are and if you're watching this video I
love you thank you for being here you
are probably the happiest most
optimistic most positive most caring
most pouring into other people that's in
your environment like if you think about
you and your friends and your family
you're you're the most optimistic person
in your family you're the most positive
person in your family you're the most
ambitious person in your family you're
the one who wants to care and serve the
most in your family right
but you know you're capable of way way
more right you know you can do way more
than what you're doing right
now and so you end up being this big
fish in a really tiny pond where you're
serving others and pointing others and
you wish they could do more and that's
amazing don't stop caring for others but
you need more of a push yourself you
need to be around the people who are
doing things that you want to do on a
higher level so the environment really
matters in your environment right now is
is good it's it's not terrible maybe it
is terrible but it's not great most
likely it's just good and it keeps you
stuck and it keeps you in slow growth
mode and it prevents you from becoming
the person that you actually want to be
so how do you start to shift that well
you shift your environment and you may
say well Evan I don't know people who
are super accomplished and are living
the life that I want to live I don't
have any of those friends if I did I
wouldn't be still stuck here and I hear
hear you I get it so the fastest way to
do it isn't through actually trying to
make those friends it's through what I
call aspirational mentors it's by
watching videos like this you may never
meet me you may never meet Mel Robbins
you may never meet whoever your heroes
are but you can learn from it through
these videos whoever you want more of
whoever you you respect and maybe are
even jealous of that they can think that
way and live that way be around them
more look at who you subscribe to on
YouTube look at who you subscribe to and
follow on Instagram look at the books
you read and the podcasts you listen to
and the shows that you watch are they
from the people who make you feel better
about yourself and give you hope
inspiration and courage to go Live Your
Dream and if not then switch it out
switch it
out if you are watching YouTube and you
just found that you you wasted the last
three hours of your
life it's not YouTube's
fault it's your fault you're subscribed
and watching the wrong videos because
there's a lot of positivity out there if
you close a YouTube session and you feel
worse about yourself then you subscribe
to the wrong channels if you're watching
this video and feel worse about yourself
one I sincerely apologize and two you
should unfollow me and go follow
somebody that that makes you feel more
hopeful and Alive because if you started
your day with the thing that made you
feel hopeful alive bold confident
powerful things are possible your life
will change but we need that external
stimulus you are a product of your
environment you have to have those
people around you you can have Elon Musk
and Mel Robbins and Tony Robins and
whoever pushing you every day you can
have them pushing you every
day by consuming their content we just
happen to be
enslaved
by the things that are around us that we
haven't designed with intention that's
all you know YouTube the algorithm is so
addictive so addictive you you get one
video that then takes you down another
path and another path and all of a
sudden you've just watched 3 hours of
videos on something that doesn't make
your life better and you don't actually
really care about you just got sucked
into the drama of a certain storyline
has that ever happened to
you remember I watched the Michael
Jordan tribute the last dance and I went
to
research one of the storylines of Scotti
Pippen and and Michael Jordan to see
kind of what the 2022 updated version
was and all of a sudden I got down this
Rabbit Hole of Scotti Pitman versus
Michael Jordan and 3 hours later there's
still other videos to watch like what am
I doing this is a waste of time I don't
even care that much about these guys I
watched the last dance it was a great
documentary and and I learned from it
and I love the drive and tenacity and
hustle but I don't care about the drama
between Michael Jordan and Scotty Pippen
and so we will easily default back into
that Comfort mode and back into to
consuming
drama you have to with intention try to
bring that back so here's a great
homework assignment go look at your
YouTube homepage and see what's being
recommended to you and how many of those
videos whether it's my Channel or other
channels how many of those how many of
the videos on your homepage right now
will make you a better human will make
you feel more proud of yourself will
make you feeling hopeful confident
courageous ready to take some action on
some of your goals and how many of them
are drama how many of them are pure
entertainment how many of them you know
will lead to some giant rabbit hole that
you don't want to go down if you
actually set out your calendar and say
how do I want to spend my day with
intention how many of these videos would
actually lead you towards that path
right and for too many people it's it's
not a it's not a pretty picture we're
listening to the wrong people and so you
can change that you know you can change
that if we Circle back you recognize
that the negative a voice in your head
is not your voice it was planted there
by somebody else who hates their life
and you don't want their life then you
switch it to say okay well whose life do
I want and ultimately you want your best
version of your life but to get there
you're taking different pieces from
different people's lives like oh I like
how he does that and she does that and
and she does this and you're pulling
different people different things from
different
people and then you start to surround
yourself with that and the shift doesn't
happen overnight but if you're
constantly pouring these people into you
if you're constantly pouring Evan
Carmichael into you you're going to
start to believe more in
yourself and if you're constantly
pouring other people into you're going
to start thinking like them behaving
like them taking on their mindsets and
their beliefs and if those are beliefs
that you want and the mindset that you
want amazing you get to choose now
you're in
control you've been a product of your
environment your early environment with
NE negativity your ongoing environment
with probably just mediocrity keeping
you where you are and now you can change
it you can shift it you can decide to be
in a different spot when you're from
today and the most important step you
can do is to start choosing and
carefully decide with intention who you
want to be around so that in one year
from now you are in a different spot not
just for you but so you can serve others
and lift them up to catch up as well
rule number two
believe 95% of the world wakes up and
drives to a job that they hate I believe
that you have Michael Jordan level
Talent at something that you are a
genius you are the best the best at
something most people either one have no
idea what that thing is or two they have
found it but they don't have the courage
or belief to go chase it down either way
the path is through you need to find the
thing that you are a genius at that you
have Michael Jordan level Talent at and
and live it every single day if you want
to live your life instead of regret your
life this is why I do what I do I want
people to believe in themselves more I I
look at people and I I see this person
who hates their life and and then
there's so much talent you have so much
talent you want to serve you want to
help others you want to make an impact
you want to make a difference everybody
does it's a human condition and you know
you're capable of more than what you're
doing right now you know it and this is
what I want to help bring out in people
it's why I make the videos that I do and
write the Books and do the my speaking
all of it cuz I want to pull that out I
want you to suck on whatever energy that
I can give you so that you then realize
maybe I am a genius maybe I do have
great ideas maybe maybe what I have
could actually change the world maybe I
need to stop doing the thing that I'm
doing maybe I maybe there is some hope
right that's what I want to try to
inject into people and so I have an
eight-step process that I'll take you
through super quick that if you are are
are struggling with belief if you are
struggling thinking that I don't know if
I'm a genius at something this process
will help you it'll help you believe in
your big Ideas it'll help you believe in
your capabilities and I'll help you go
off and actually make an impact let's
dive in number one let find your purpose
you got to find out what the thing is
that you're here to do right I have my
who I how process figure out who what
your one word is your most important
core value two your purpose comes from
your pain thing that you struggle the
most with is the thing that you want to
help other people through whatever you
struggled the most with the worst moment
in your life whatever you remember that
is your purpose for life will be helping
other people who are currently going
through that pain and then three the how
how you got out of it how you got
through it will be a recipe to teach
other people you'll be able to as you
take your steps on the staircase Up Lift
other people up to join you on that step
so step number one in believing in
yourself more is figuring out what is
your purpose step number two is going
from idea to action you have great ideas
you have great ideas the problem is you
judge your ideas you come up with a
great idea in the shower and then you
spend the rest of the day thinking about
about it researching planning it judging
it saying I can't do that or how's that
going to work and then you wake up
tomorrow a different person the faster
you go from idea to action will will
dictate your entire future it'll change
the entire trajectory of your life the
faster you go from idea to action stop
judging your ideas you get an idea you
go for it you do it the 2% difference
stop planning to get to 100% and just
take action on the first 2% you'll never
figure out the whole plan by sitting on
your couch you won't you figure it out
by doing idea action train yourself you
get an idea you do something about it
cuz your ideas list is never going to
get any shorter it's growing every day
you're a genius you come with great
ideas but it's not enough you got to do
something about them and so immediate
action you get an idea Boom the 2%
difference what's one thing that you can
do that'll take you 2% of the way to
making some momentum on this idea the
smallest simplest dumbest stupidest
thing that you can do right now today on
your idea idea to action step three is
model success H have people around you
who inspire you who lift you up who show
you that is possible I love my YouTube
channel for for myself I need it for me
I surround myself with Steve Jobs and
Kanye and Oprah and all these people for
me for myself I want it I want to be
around successful people because what it
does it rubs off on you it rubs off it's
like they're sprinkling little Steve
Jobs pixie dust on you it rubs off it
shows you two things one that it's
possible because all of your Heroes they
started with less than what you
currently have right now you feel like
it's overwhelming and impossible in your
environment and it's just it's never
going to happen whoever you look up to
whoever your heroes are they had it
worse than you have it right now they
struggled through worse than what you're
struggling through right now and so if
they could do it you can't too there's
no excuse if you're surrounded by people
who just tell you oh take it easy take
it slow yeah of course of course you
can't do it because you were born a X or
because you come from this community of
course yeah just you're never going to
make it right screw the president screw
the system right
most people that's how they live but
other people they've won they've done it
despite coming from worse circumstances
than you you have no excuse and so when
you surround yourself with those people
who are of and winning who who look like
you came from the same background as you
struggle with the same things as you or
worse it's motivating it gives you hope
that it's possible you need to be around
success you need to model it and and it
gives you the hope and it also gives you
strategies Bill Gates saved my company
I've never met him yet but but what he
did give me hope that what I wanted to
do was possible with my software company
and how he got through was a recipe for
me I modeled how he got through it and
that started to take my company forward
so step three and believe in yourself
more is you need to model success step
four is create an environment of
Excellence an environment of Excellence
what in your environment makes you feel
excellent it starts with you how you
carry yourself I love wearing this right
like I wear this not just for the camera
I like it like I feel like Batman
putting on my outfit putting on my
superhero cape right when I wear this
how do you want to express yourself from
the clothes you wear from from your
haircuts from the jewelry you put on how
do you going to express yourself that is
excellent that reminds you of who you
are and what you're capable of next you
go out to your physical environment so
these people are all behind me for a
reason I walk into this office and
without even have to think about it I've
got these people staring me down
reminding me to be excellent to go chase
down my dreams right what's on your
what's on your cell phone background
what's on your computer computer
background right these are things that
you set up once in your environment and
then it triggers you I call them play
bigger triggers they're there for you
every single day to remind you right if
I'm if I'm feeling low if I feel like I
don't believe in myself enough I got my
parents right here telling me hey Evan
you're you're kichel believe in yourself
more if I'm struggling with my vision I
got Steve J I got Steve Jobs staring me
down right here right I'm my this is my
computer I'm looking here I got this guy
eyes on me right now maybe that's too
creepy for you scary for you awesome
design for yourself design for Your
Excellence what makes you feel bold and
want to come alive and have that as a
daily part of your routine step number
five is schedule for Success so I just
mentioned routines what is your routine
what are you doing on a daily basis show
me how the actions that you're doing
what's in your calendar will help you
accomplish your goals right your actions
have to map to your Ambitions you say
you want this amazing I love it I'm
pumped now show me your calendar where
you're going to do it you say you want
to have a million subscribers on YouTube
amazing you say you want to sell a
million books amazing you say you want
to have a million dollar business
amazing show me your calendar where you
spending your time on making videos on
writing books on building your business
like it has to be in your calendar most
people they don't have it in your
calendar and if if you don't have in
your calendar it's never going to get
done and not just business life success
you want to be a successful husband
father mother daughter wife anything
where's that time put in your calendar
right show me your calendar your
calendar is your habits and your habits
will dictate your success and so what
you do on a weekly basis in your
calendar and also how you start your day
every day most people wake up like an
accident most people wake up they hit
the snooze button which already you're
telling yourself that you you're the
kind of person who doesn't follow
through on your goals and you start
responding to other people's emergencies
no start your day with intention you
could have had the greatest day of all
time yesterday and you wake up today and
it's you're starting over so what makes
you come alive and then put that into
your morning routine with intention
every day so you stop waking up like an
accident you do that you're going to
believe in yourself more step number six
to believe in yourself more is
manufacturing self-confidence
manufacture self-confidence you do
difficult things you need to teach
yourself that you do difficult things
that when something is hard you want to
do it you love hard things that when
your heart's beaten and you're scared
you're nervous that's a sign you have to
go do that thing self-confidence self-
Lov self- resect comes from following
through on the things you say you're
going to do but it doesn't count until
it's difficult waking up at X in the
morning right you want to wake up at
6:00 in the morning great when it's easy
it doesn't count you don't feel good
about yourself you don't feel bad it's
just it's easy it's when it's hard it's
when it's hard right if you if you ran a
race against three-year-olds right and
you won you might post about it say yeah
I won this race but inside you know it's
a fake you know it's a fake win it
doesn't count but if you get up and run
against Usain Bolt he's going to destroy
you but you can feel good that you
tried right are you proud of your effort
you want to manufacture self-confidence
you want more belief are you proud of
yourself today and it's not something
that that anybody else can give
you should I be proud of myself I don't
know did I do enough reps I don't know
did I did I write enough words for my
book I don't know are you proud of
yourself I can tell you when I broke my
neck on my tour and I was sitting at the
front for three and a half hours in
massive pain delivering my presentation
I was proud of myself even though the
quality went down right I was better
when I was being able to walk around and
not have so much pain I felt like my
presentation delivery was better but I
was more proud of myself for doing it
when it was hard that's how you
manufacture self-confidence that's how
you manufacture self-belief it's doing
it when it's hard it does not count
until it's hard and that you do
difficult things step number seven to
believe in yourself more is beating
negative judgment if you're doing
anything that's different anything
that's outside the norm guess what
there's a lot of people who love the
norm there's a lot of people who will
say Hey you suck like stop doing this
they want to protect the status quo
because if you go off and win it makes
them look bad it makes them feel bad
about thems right you you winning makes
them feel bad abouts and so you're going
to have a lot of people who all they
focus on is tearing other people down
you may even have your parents who who
are who are giving you advice out of
love but your parents are pilgrims you
are growing up in a different era than
they did if you're if you're 20 years
old right now your parents are 20 years
old the world is different
different the the amount of things that
a 20-year-old can do right now to build
a business to have success to make a a
meaningful impact on the world is crazy
compared to what was available when your
parents were 20 years old they don't
understand the world that you live in
and so their advice is out of love but
they just don't understand what's
possible and so you get advice that's
out of love that's still negative you'll
see it as negative and you'll also get
hate you'll get people who watch your
videos or read your book and say you
suck that's the worst thing I've ever
seen in my life but what's the
alternative to never ruffle any feathers
to never do anything bold or big or
great to to live your entire life in
fear of being rejected in fear of people
laughing at you and so you play small
your whole life and then you're 95 you
look back and say I never did anything
great I knew I was capable I never did
it you need to learn to attack judgment
you attack it if you're afraid of even
the possibility of judgment then you do
it it's why I painted my nails a while
back cuz I was afraid of people judging
me for having my nails painted so then I
had to do it it you have to do it just
to beat it just to eat the Judgment you
need to train yourself cuz if you want
to go off and do some some amazing big
thing but you can't do something as
simple as painting your nails you've
lost you're so worried about other
people's opinions that you'll play small
forever and so the next time you feel
yourself worried about somebody else's
opinion then you have to go off and do
that thing now within your code of
ethics right don't go don't go beat
somebody up don't go you know mock
somebody don't don't do something
against your values but most things that
you want to do you want to do it's for
you it's not against somebody else you
want to do it for you and you're afraid
of what the reaction is going to be
that's the fear that you need to quash
and as soon as you catch it you need to
say I'm going to do it I'm going to I'm
going to beat that negative judgment I'm
going to feel that fear and I'm going to
do it anyway and then step number eight
to getting more belief is to make an
impact we want to make an impact making
money is important it has to be money
has to be in your top five it's just not
number one money's not number one it's
not number 100 on your list either it's
got to be in your top five but something
comes ahead of it and that's the impact
that you want to have what is the impact
how you going to do it and then start
feeling it start seeing it start start
appreciating it you know for me I'm I'm
just here in my office talking to the
camera it's me and the camera alone in a
room but it's going out and being
broadcast and you're watching it right
now and I appreciate that and I and I
remind myself of the work that I do
every day matters is touching people and
maybe that's just one person maybe maybe
you helped one person today and you feel
the impact of that or maybe it's 100 or
a thousand or 100,000 however it might
right your impact will continue to grow
with time especially entrepreneurs we we
want to have a big impact not just one
person at a time but remembering that
that you're here to do something good
and that your work matters if you woke
up every day and felt like the work that
you do matters to somebody is having an
impact on somebody it's serving other
people cuz humans are built to serve and
if you felt like that every single day
man your life would be dramatically
different also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number three find your core value
if you don't get this right your
business will fail it's not just about
what you love doing and the skill sets
you have it's about having similar core
values as the people that you bring on
board you need to know what your who is
you need to know what you stand for as a
human being you need to know what your
mission is and bring people on board who
have similar core values this is where
so many Entre R preneurs fail if you
only do a self assessment and say well
I'm great at this I'm going to be the
technician I'm going to be the artist
I'm going to be the coder I'm going to
be the one doing all of the actual work
and I need to partner up with somebody
who's a business person who's going to
be doing the deals and the media and
raising the capital and talking to
investors and doing the sales pitches
it's not enough to say well I'm good at
this and you're good at this so let's
get together and that's what so many
people do that's why so many business
Partnerships fail because you're just
looking at it on paper you're just
saying well they have the skill sets I
don't have great let's work together
boom we're in business and often times
entrepreneurs will then say hey well
let's do 50/50 right you're bringing
this I'm bringing this so here we go
50/50 partnership and for those who've
been through it before you know how much
of a disaster that can be because
everything looks good on paper but you
can't make a decision just based off of
paper it's like going to a dating
website and putting in your ideal person
and then deciding to marry that person
without ever going on on a
date it's about core values why do
Things Fall Apart because you don't
share the same core
values and a lot of times you don't even
know what your own core value is to
start with so you figure out your one
word your most important core value
that's the starting point you have to
figure it out I mean it'll serve you not
just for your business but for any
relationship for life this is what you
stand for as a human and then you want
to attract people who not just have the
skill set and the desire but the same
core value because you know what the
skill set is actually easier to teach
than the core value to make somebody
change their beliefs I don't know how to
do it it's crazy it's it's ridiculous to
give somebody a new skill set is way
easier to teach I wasn't very good at
making videos at the start I practiced I
I busted my face I kept going I kind of
I busted my neck I kept going and I got
better at it even though I sucked at the
beginning go back and watch my first
video had no natural talent for this but
I picked up the skill through repetition
you can pick up the skill through
repetition but picking up a core value
is really difficult and so we don't
scream for this we don't look for this
we don't try to find this out in people
we're jumping into relationships way too
quickly because it just makes logical
sense and then you realize six months in
man you're screwed and you can't get out
of this partnership you're you're
handcuffed now cuz they own half of your
business and so here's a process that I
think you should follow one you start
with understanding what is your most
important core value I wrote a book on
it you can pick it up your one word but
just think about it if you had one core
value that you stood for as a human more
than all the other ones what is it it's
always something positive mine believe
I've seen a whole bunch of of things
it's it's never something negative it's
never hate it's never death I've never
had somebody's one word be something
negative you need to figure out what it
is that you stand for it's the most
important exercise you'll ever do in
your life two now you build a business
around it and you start a attracting the
people in who believe the same thing you
believe so as an example when I'm doing
a job posting for someone on my team
right we've got 24 people on the team
when I'm doing a new job posting it'll
always lead with belief so if I'm
looking for a programmer for my website
it'll lead with belief believe why I
believe in entrepreneurs what the
mission I'm on what believe means to me
the impact that I want to have on the
world not talking about the job at all
just the mission believe the core value
because what I want to do is eliminate
the people people who don't care about
that some people will see that job ad
and say I'm a programmer like what what
does that to do with Bel this is stupid
great don't apply you're saving both of
us a lot of time because you might have
all the skills that I need but if you
don't have the same core value or at
least we're aligned somehow on the core
values we're not going to work well
together you shouldn't be here you
should be somewhere else and we'll both
be happy it's not that I'm better than
you you just won't be we won't be happy
together we won't mix well cuz we have
different core values go somewhere else
else and then in the job ble get to what
the offer is about what the opportunity
is what the position's all about what
the requirements
are a lot of people will self- eliminate
and that's amazing you want them to but
other people will look at that job at
and say holy cow I love this this is
exactly the thing that I've been looking
for like where has this person been my
whole life where has this opportunity
been my whole I love this this is
exactly what I want to do and what
they'll do is they'll work harder to
impress you they'll work harder on their
resume and their cover letter and in the
interviews and doing extra work because
they believe the same thing you believe
and so it's just such an important
missing piece of the criteria that most
people go through we look to hire people
and work with people just based off of
skill set and of course is
important if you want to start a a a
technical shop and you're hiring
somebody or working with somebody who
has zero technical skills can they learn
it absolutely but it's probably going to
take them a window of time to get there
may not be fast enough for you to build
your
business but we default too much to the
skills we default too much to the actual
work they're doing and not enough to the
inside not enough to what they actually
believe in and whether you're applying
that philosophy to employees to
investors to Partners to relationships
to friendships to anybody who you have
to deal with when you around people who
believe similar things that you believe
you can go so much faster and if you
have any anybody around you that's
bringing you down do you have that one
toxic relationship for whatever reason
even if they have all the skills in the
world that drags you down and chances
are it's because you guys just have
different core values and you shouldn't
be working together it's better to
figure that out from the start instead
of waiting 6 months being a 50/50
partner and killing your business rule
number four change your standards you
are where you are in life and business
because of your standards it's just not
important enough for you yet to hit that
next level for you for me for all of us
we've settled we've settled for what
currently is and haven't demanded from
ourselves that we reach that next level
change your standards change your life
so I was recently talking to Alex on my
team and he helps me run Toronto dance
salsa the largest dance school for salsa
in North America probably and he
recently went through this weight loss
challenge and and he lost C I don't know
I want to say 30 lb and now he's
sticking to this really thin line of
between 150 and 155 lbs that's his goal
that's his standard when he's when he's
getting close to 155 he slows down on
the eating and when he's around 150 he
has a little bit more and he's
constantly staying in this band because
he set a new standard for himself even
though he might have been 180 or 185
before now anywhere close to 155 is
going to be too much like that's it
that's my new standard that's the lowest
I'm going to go which is crazy high
compared to what he was before he's now
trying to bring that same standard to
his business so what he's trying to do
every day now if you follow him on
Instagram is he's posting at the end of
the day how proud he is of the effort he
put in how proud is he of the effort
that he put in at a 10 and sometimes you
see it's 5.5 sometimes you see it's a
seven and every now and then it's an
eight or even a nine how proud he is of
the effort that he put in this is now
the area where he needs to raise his
standards and I was talking to him
yesterday and a big breakthrough that
happened was said Alex you lost 30 lbs
man or more from your weight loss
Journey now the idea of being over 155
is crazy when you used to be 180 right
or 185 it's crazy you need to take that
same approach to your business to your
effort that you're proud of yourself
every day for what you're doing anything
under eight should be considered a cheat
day anything under eight is like you had
a cheat day on your diet every now and
then on his his weight loss Journey he
had a cheat day he had a moment of
weakness he he went for a giant pizza
and a cake because he was starving and
he couldn't control himself but it was
these one-off moments right it was like
once every 3 weeks or something and and
he continued down that now needs to be
your daily effort if it's under eight
that's like you're eating cake and pizza
eight needs to be the new waterline that
if you're getting close to it it's like
holy cow I can't I need to work hard I
need to I need to accomplish I need to
go off and do
just like 155 now is that Benchmark for
himself and putting into those terms
made sense for him because he had higher
standards now for himself in what he ate
in how he took care of his body than he
did for what he was doing into his
business and so it's the same thing for
you you want to grow you want to get
better you want to improve you have to
raise your standards you have to now not
settle for where you're at CU where
you're at is good this is the problem
good is the enemy of great right where
you're at good it's good it's not
amazing but it doesn't suck cuz if it
sucked if you hated it every day you
would have to find a way out but because
it's good you don't do it you don't
change it's not important enough for you
to want to get to that next step that's
what I want to force in this video I'm
going to give you three ways to do it
step number one is understand where do
you need to have a higher standard where
in your life do you need to have a
higher standard what's the thing that
you want more of Alex did it in his
health and his weight now he's applying
to his business in his life for you
where is it is it your health is it your
business is it learning the skill set is
it posting cont content every day like
where is it that you need to have a
higher stand for yourself be specific be
clear write it down step number two is
surround yourself with it daily one of
the greatest things that you need to do
that really helps you raise your
standards is be around people who are
more High achieving in that thing be
around people who are more High
achieving in the thing that you want to
get great at the thing that you are weak
at so if I was hanging around
bodybuilders all day I'd probably work
out a lot more right because everybody's
doing it because they have a higher
standard where I might let myself off
the hook for not doing a workout I'm
going to see them crushing it they're
going to lift me up they'll just have to
they'll lift me up and I'm going to make
them believe in themselves more that's
just going to happen I was on Twitch
streaming last night League of Legends
and a guy said man you're so positive
twitch is such a a negative toxic place
and you're here spreading positivity
like yeah and I'll keep doing it and no
matter no matter who comes in who's
negative and toxic I am more confident
in my positivity and belief than you are
in your negative ity and toxicity and so
I will make you doubt yourself because
of my confidence whoever is more
confident wins and so the trick is
you're very confident in some things and
not so confident in other things the
things that you want to get good at
right things that you want to get great
at the things that you want to get great
at not good things you want to get great
at you don't have a high degree of
confidence in your ability to do it you
need to be around people who have a high
degree of confidence and are doing it
whether that's actually face to face but
it could be through videos it could
could be through books it could be
through podcasts if you are trying to
get healthy you're trying to lose weight
you're trying to gain strength and
you're following people on Instagram and
watching videos that motivate you every
day it's in your environment every day
it will it will just pull you up my
videos my channels I use for myself
because it makes me feel more believ I
surround myself with Tony Robbins every
day and Steve Jobs every day and Kanye
West every day and Oprah Winfrey every
day they're in my ear they're in my ear
they're pulling me up and they can do
that for you as well so whatever it is
that you want to raise your standard in
surround yourself every day with that
content with those people and then step
number three is schedule for Success the
mindset is the first part but then you
got to do something you want to
accomplish a new level amazing what are
you going to do every day show me in
your calendar pull out your calendar
pull out your you know week to week from
this Sunday until the next Sunday from
seven days in between what are you going
to do show me in your calendar where
you're spending time developing this new
habit fixing your new mindset putting
the actual work in you want to gain
muscle awesome it's great to be around
people who are doing it but then you
have to actually put in your calendar
I'm going to go to the gym I'm going to
start lifting some weights you want to
create YouTube content amazing it's
great maybe to be inspired watching me
or other YouTube creators but nothing
happens until you pick up your phone and
you start filming something and that has
to be in your calendar if you hope for
something to happen it's never it's not
going to happen if you hope for
something to happen it's not going to
happen right this is something that you
have a slipping standard on you know you
want to get better at and so it has to
be in your calendar you you have to
schedule for Success this is what new
success looks like for you great your
success is your habits so schedule it in
that every week or every day or every
month however often you need to do it
it's in there it's happening you're
going to raise your standards because of
it rule number five the last one before
our very special bonus clip just do you
you don't do you because you're afraid
of negative judgment you're afraid of
what your family will think you're
afraid of what your friends will think
you're afraid of what total strangers
will think you'll sing in the shower but
you won't sing outside walking down the
street why it's not because you're
afraid of failing it's because you're
afraid of failing in front of other
people until you crush that fear of
judgment from other people you will
never accomplish the big goals in your
life and today I'm going to show you how
so last weekend I was in Dallas I was
doing a speech at video marketing World
which is a fantastic event put on every
year in Dallas where some of the top
video creators come to try to help other
people are trying to get started in
video marketing build their business and
I had a really important session at the
front and I was nervous going into it
because I just made a big move on my
YouTube channel my main Channel I split
into eight or nine multiple different
channels so now instead of just running
my main Channel we got channels like
this which is dedicated to its own
channel now when I was thinking about
doing a move it was recommended to Me by
Matt gelan who's one of five people who
who I would really listen to for YouTube
advice there's five people in the world
who said Evan you suck on YouTube here
are the things that you should do to get
better right I'm at The Cutting Edge
there's five people who would listen to
one of them is M Gillan and he told me
to split up my channel another one of
the five is Jeremy vest and he told me
don't do the split up I've known Jeremy
for a number of years he's helped me a
lot I've helped him a lot I really
respect his opinion he said do not split
up the channels it's better to keep them
all on one channel and so I'm faced with
the Dilemma which one do I do and I
decid deed that I'd rather no one fail
than not know that I would rather do it
because I know what my channel looks
like now having all the videos on one
channel I know what that looks like I
didn't know what having multiple
channels look like and so I'd rather
know one fail than not know but here's
the thing why do I tell this story
because when I'm in Dallas the person
who was putting on the event was Jeremy
vest the guy who told me not to split up
the channels the guy who said this is a
mistake you shouldn't do it you should
keep all the videos on one channel and
what did I end up doing I did the
opposite right I did what Matt said and
not Jeremy and so I knew this question
would come up when I was on stage
because everybody there knew that I had
split up my channels and was wondering
how it would work out and my default
response as I thought about it was I
don't want to go deep into the story
because Jeremy is here in the room and
this is his event he's not just
attending he's hosting it this is his
event I don't want to make him feel bad
I don't want to make it seem like he's
on a spot or that I wouldn't want to
listen to his advice because I love him
and respect him and I love hearing his
perspective but the fact that I was
afraid of it meant that I had to do it
that's something that I've trained
myself to do that I want you to train
yourself to do as well that the fact
that you are afraid of what somebody
else is going to say or think means you
have to do it you have to step into it
you can't teach yourself that when you
think of something and you're afraid
that you play small it's better not even
to think about it's better not to catch
your insecurity when you catch it you
have to train yourself to go off and do
it and then I defaulted thinking okay
well how can I do this in a way that is
respectful to Jeremy that is loving to
Jeremy that that I I can show people how
much I appreciate his feedback that I
don't make him look bad at his own event
how can I do that and then that question
asking leads you to better answers and
so it came up just like I thought it was
going to come up and I talked about it
and Jeremy wasn't offended and Jeremy
did not look bad and I accomplished my
objective and I did it made myself feel
proud cuz I was nervous because I was
afraid and so that's what I want to
teach you that the next time that you're
afraid the next time you're feeling
small the next time you're worried about
somebody else's opinions of you that you
go and you take action that you do the
thing because you cannot play small for
life if you are worried about what
people think of you you will never
accomplish the big goals in your
business because you have big goals
you're an entrepreneur you want to do
amazing things you have big Ambitions
that will never happen if you're afraid
of what one person's going to think of
you because as your vision is bigger the
more people are going to attack you and
you need to develop that thick skin and
and ask yourself how can I do it how can
I take my Approach with as much caring
compassion understanding as possible but
I need to get out there and put my
message forward now if you're struggling
with this I have a three-step process
I'm going to walk you through that I
think will help step number one is the
boom boom boom test so as I was telling
that story you might have seen me tap my
chest here right this is the boom boom
boom test when your heart is going boom
boom boom boom boom that's a a sign to
go it's go time it's showtime let's move
we're making this happen train yourself
that when you feel nervous scared your
heart's beaten out of your chest like
this that you have to step into it and
do it now as long as you're not
violating your code of ethics right
we're not going to steal from somebody
because it makes your heart go boom
we're not going to jump out of an
airplane with no parachute because it
makes you afraid right don't do
something stupid most of the things
you're afraid of though are around other
people's judgments other people's
expectations other people's opinions
iions that's what mostly causes this
we're afraid of letting people down
we're afraid of looking bad in front of
somebody's eyes right when you feel that
if you can catch it cuz a lot of times
you won't catch it you'll just play
small by default I think we've play
small by default but when you do Catch
It you teach yourself I feel my heart
beating out of my chest that means it is
go time number two is understand that
it's not fatal it's not fatal whatever
the thing is that you're trying to do is
not fatal if you make a mistake even if
I made Jeremy look really bad on stage
right even if I went in with with love
and compassion and I and I screwed up
the whole story it's still not fatal I
can still make it up to him I can still
go back and show him insane love and
apologize right it's not fatal whatever
you're worried about whatever this
judgment is that you're afraid is
holding you back cuz somebody's going to
look at you and say something it's not
fatal that's not going to stick with you
for life people move on you're not that
important that video that you put up
that you think everybody's going to
laugh at and and say what an
embarrassment tomorrow they want to
something else nobody's going to
remember tomorrow next week next year 5
years 10 years 20 years that you made
this embarrassing video but you will
remember not doing it you will remember
in one day one week 1 year 5 years 10
years 20 years you will remember you
will remember in 20 years that you did
not take your shot that you did not do
the thing that you wanted to do because
you were afraid you will remember but
nobody else will you will remember if
you don't do do it and nobody else will
if you do you have to do it you got to
step up and tell yourself that this
thing even though it's scary even though
it's making your heart boom boom boom
like this it is not fatal you can
recover and step number three is take
the pillow test I need a pillow where's
a pillow this is one of my favorite
things to do the pillow test the pillow
test is you've got this pillow right
you're going to sleep at night this is
you at night sleeping like a baby M I
had such a great day I changed so many
lives sleeping like a baby right that's
you okay great before you put your head
on the pillow here at night you have to
make yourself proud and this is
something that only you can tell you
about I can't tell you if you should be
proud of yourself or not your friends
your family your husband wife your kids
nobody else can but you this is an
inside job do you feel proud of yourself
today for the actions and the effort
that you put in not the results the
actions and the efforts you were nervous
you were scared you did it whether you
wanton or not whether you accomplish or
not I don't care I care that you did it
I care that you made yourself proud so
tonight before you put your head on the
pillow before you go to sleep and think
about what an amazing life you have
right before you do that ask yourself
did I make myself proud did I do
something that was scary that made
myself proud and if yes great go to
sleep if not get out of bed and go do
something send an email commit to
somebody post something make a video
something something to make yourself
feel proud because if you woke up every
day and sometime during that day you did
something that made you scared that then
made you feel proud of your yourself
that when you take the pillow test and
sleep tonight you're proud of the effort
you put in holy cow I guarantee you're
going to generate some amazing results
over the next month 6 months 12 months
24 months rest of your
life I think it's really important for
entrepreneurs to understand where your
threshold is of how much crap you could
take from other people how much
negativity how much feedback and
criticism that you can take without it
impacting your psyche your self worth I
think in general as an entrepreneur you
need to be prepared to get a lot of crap
a lot of negativity a lot of stuff
thrown at you and yes it's easy to say
don't care what other people think but
understanding what your tolerance level
is and where you kind of fit on that
Spectrum can really help you design the
rules so that they're in your favor so
as an example this is a guy on my team
who doesn't handle criticism as well you
know I'm a lot more comfortable in the
uncomfortable where he can bounce around
a lot more he'll be on top of the world
like this is great and then a negative
feedback comes in and it really impacts
him hardly and then the positive one
comes in and he jumps back up and so for
someone like him you can't design as
much risk as much negativity or
potential negativity so you got to take
a a safe path up where for me I'm more
comfortable in the uncomfortable I know
that eventually something's going to
work out and I know that at the
beginning of any project it's going to
be rough that it may not work out that
we're gonna get some criticism and so
I'm more willing to jump all in and play
in that field even though it's painful
at the moment because I know the faster
I get through that pain the faster we're
going to come out the other side I want
that feedback and criticism and
negativity as soon as possible so that I
can make it better better for you better
for me better for everybody and so
understanding what your tolerance level
is of emotional stability how much you
can take from your friends and your
family and your customers and your
audience and the people watching you
before you break and then be able to
play just below that limit cuz you can't
just play Super safe cuz that's not
going to make you happy as an
entrepreneur but KN where your limit is
and playing just below it so that it's
uncomfortable it's painful but you're
still going to be able to get through it
I think is really important that
self-awareness I think is really
important as an
entrepreneur because you made it this
far in a video I want to celebrate you
most people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
and if you want to watch evans's top 10
rules for Success check out the video
next to me I think you can enjoy
continue to believe I will see you there
there's a lot of talk in the Creator
Community now about burnout you know
people one year in on their career and
they're burning out it's like well I've
been doing this for 14 years and haven't
burnt out yet I still love the process
of doing the thing so what is work